I'm waiting on our
pasture raised cowshare
to be ready for pickup
so I restocked on some
grass fed beef
and a pasture raised chicken for bone broth
got some sprouts for easy micronutrients
cucumbers and onions for pickling
I love this raw cheese
and pasture cottage cheese
for easy protein
and then raw kefir
for beneficial microbes
and holy butter
both coconut water and dates
are good sources of potassium
and then mushrooms have
so many health benefits
fruits an obvious one
because it's an easy carb
& packed full of micronutrients
and antioxidants
avocados for saturated fat
limes for electrolytes
and then these two are
always in our fridge
and though these ones are not
from this grocery haul
these are sprouts favorites
that are literally always in my kitchen